hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
what we are doing today is looking at
twelve typical fights that happen in
pretty much every fortnight battle
royale match I've put together reliable
approaches to each confrontation and
hopefully a way to come out victorious
in each of them let's get one thing
straight right away I'm a distinctly
average player with pretty poor old man
reactions so if I can get wins using
these tips then you'll be working bit is
all day except for John wick skins those
guys have got issues add all these
strats to your play style and you'll be
a force to be reckoned with we'll start
with the easy stuff and build tomorrow
advanced strategies so please stick
around until the end I'm not going to
treat you like a noob
I'm sure you've already had hundreds of
one-on-one battles you know how to build
and you know how to shoot but I do need
to make sure if you're playing on
console that you're using the new
builder Pro option this will
revolutionize your building options and
therefore improve your overall game
after selecting build mode each of the
shoulder buttons constructs a different
tile are two built walls l2 ramps l1
pyramids and r1 flaws give it a few days
and I promise it's the best option for
all players with that out of the way
let's look at each fighting fortnight
and the best approach for each encounter
let's start with an easy one I want on
one fight when the opposition hasn't a
clue you are there you may think
engaging will automatically win the
fight but you're actually lowering your
chances of success in the battle by a
lack of preparation the most common
thing you should do in this and every
single other scenario is build a ramp
sounds basic I know but before every
fight place a ramp even if you have the
drop on your target it's for a number of
reasons first it's the high ground
not all one-on-one fights are made equal
as the hills and valleys in fortnight
means someone will always have the high
ground not only does that high ground up
your chances of hitting the headshot it
also diminishes your opponent's chances
of hitting your dome additionally think
of the ramp as insurance as it offers
cover if you lucky offer shot at the
target a mistake which I regularly make
see the ramp as a safety net to hide
behind when reloading healing or
scouting for foe
the ramp is your friend so bloody use
the thing next up is another very
general tip in one-on-one fights which
if used correctly can end bite
immediately if you have the drop on
someone use your sniper rifle or hunting
rifle these beasts may only have a
single round and may be best for
long-range encounters but if that round
hit regardless of distance the
opposition will be rocked and near death
instantly if you hit a headshot it's
over before the fight even begins but if
not the opposition will be in such a bad
state you'll instantly have the edge in
battle but here's the key point to this
it doesn't matter if you hit the shot or
missed by a country mile think of it
like a freebie like a shot for nothing
once the shot leaves your barrel don't
reload immediately switch to your
assault rifle or your preferred weapon
to keep the pressure on your opponent
like I said in a previous video
don't stand and admire your Snipes
quickly switch the AH preferred weapon
and end the fight as soon as possible
our next typical encounter happens quite
often you may be looting or healing in
the open and a bullet hits you luckily
the opposition hasn't used tip 1 and
reins fire on you from ground level I'm
sure you already know to counter with a
quick built but the type of built you
throw up is important here consider a
defensive retreat this technique seizes
backing away but building a wall
followed by a ramp followed by a wall
followed by the ramp you get the idea
once the attacker runs out of bullets
and begins reloading climb your RAM
adding another if possible and turn the
fight in its head you'll be surprised
what a deterrent a great defense is
let's talk about ramp rushing and the
best opportunities to attack here's a
basic look in this scenario my opponent
and I create a basic ramp and wall to
attempt to engage one another I land a
few shots which causes this chap to
build higher to gain the height
advantage aggressive players usually
rush in right away but that's not for
everyone
instead there are a few signs of when
attacking is 100% the right option we
already know he's weakened and therefore
the second I see him build the
additional wall I'm on the attack the
key is to ramp one level higher than
your fault so by the time they're ready
to engage again you're already on top of
them and you end the fight of course not
all fights are so close to the ground -
the higher the opponent the less likely
a ramp rush is the
right play if you choose to rap brush
someone three or more tiles high you
should think about using the double ramp
technique it's pretty self-explanatory
it's simply two ramps side-by-side but
why do we do this
well when ramp rushing if your opponent
can't see your head
they'll instead attempt to knock down
your ramp in a single ramp rush this can
be done far too easy but by including a
second ramp or even a third in some
cases you can ascend and be relatively
safe on the way we can add to this by
using a wall to by placing a wall you
are effectively covering your ramp from
destruction
using this additional cover means your
opposition will most likely be unable to
shoot down your ramp and if done
correctly you'll be on top of your
opponent and winning the fight let's
flip this around and now we are in the
small base in this one I've just been in
a sniper battle and someone is
attempting to stealth into my base the
thing to do here is to build higher
three tiles is a perfect starting point
it doesn't use a huge amount of material
and if you are forced to jump out you
won't take fall damage sadly I was out
of material so I was forced to stay only
two tiles high here's a key mistake I
want to show you the person attacking
began ramp rushing far too late and he's
forced to run up the side of my
structure and slightly past the target
because of this poor decision he felt on
edge and completely messes up his shot
leaving me with an easy escape the point
I'm making here is to build over your
target rather than joining your ramp to
their structure basically you're a
sitting duck if you ramp rush too late
another great strategy to fool those
ramp rushes is to downright [ __ ] block
them I'm not sure where else to call it
as they approach throw down a floor tile
and completely stop their rush this
absolutely messes up attackers who are
rarely prepared they become stuck in
no-man's land
and must either backup or build around
in a flanking motion but by then you've
already got much higher and therefore in
command of the fight
speaking of flanking sometimes you go up
against someone who builds extremely
fast usually these people will lose
sight of you whilst they become the myth
for 10 seconds if you don't have the
materials to contest them use this
window to relocate if they can't find
you the high ground is absolutely
worthless
having the drop on someone can mean a
difference between life and death ok
let's move on to more advanced strategy
and how to combat master-builders
there's no easy way to do this
but there are ways to negate a fight and
reset who's in charge this will always
come down to the speed that you build
and how much pressure you feel so start
off by going to the edge of the map and
just practice building once you become
comfortable with it it becomes muscle
memory and therefore much easier to do
in a real fight but at some point you
will go up against someone who builds
better than you and you'll find yourself
stuck in this Norman's land with no way
to build higher this is when you should
use editing to restart your movement
edited or in your wall and build out and
up this is risky as heck so you'll need
to be fast but if done correctly you can
be ascending again and closing the gap
on your opponent each tile higher that
you go the pressure builds on both you
and your opponent if you can stay calm
you will win the fight in this scenario
I finally caught back up to a great
builder and after a last-ditch wall
block he had nothing left and was so
shaken he fell to his death but I salute
you anyway
myth jr. keep in mind the higher you go
means certain death if someone blows up
your structure with explosives so
descend safely and quickly generally
speaking in these giant build battles
there are two ways to progress in the
fight the first is by gaining the high
ground which you should practice every
single opportunity you get the more you
do it the more chance it will translate
into muscle memory therefore keeping you
calm when you're in real tough fights
but you can also attempt the sporadic
build method especially when you're at a
disadvantage to throw off your opponent
deceive your foe by beginning to build
one way then doubling back and going the
other as the tiles construct the
building sound gives away your location
but by building with random elements
it's possible to mislead the other
players with audio additional random
tiles on the ground also add support to
your structures just in case you're
suddenly bombarded by rockets oh and
that reminds me of how the heck do
battle against Rockets surprisingly the
best weapon against Rockets are wolves
themselves depending on how you
naturally play you'll either back away
from rockets or you will go up close and
personal in close combat
try to use a wall to block the rocket
fire you'll be surprised how many people
kill themselves because the blast is too
close to them so maybe think about being
more aggressive
rocket launchers I feel now's a good
time to admit I have killed myself
countless times with rocket launchers is
anybody else manly enough or womanly
enough to admit it to I'll be looking
through the comments to applaud that
honesty okay let's do one more but this
time I want to hear your suggestions the
dreaded launchpad attack defending this
maneuver can be difficult but still to
this day I haven't found anything better
than placing a trap in your base it's
the greatest deterrent against those
launch putters in my eyes but what if
that's not an option
another great tactic is to build hire
and deter the jumper with a few extra
inches on your erection that's a joke in
there somewhere but not convinced by
this approach what do you think and what
am I missing at this point I want to
open it up to you guys please comment
below with your solutions to any of
these battles and I'll make a follow-up
video and I'll be sure to name tech
everyone who contributes so that's it
for part one in our look at fight
strategies in battle royale thanks for
sticking around and I look forward to
talking to you in the comments I'm Adam
from Playstation grenade been a pleasure
I'll see you next time
yeah excuse me sir may I interest you in
a Houghton nanny bully don't let fine
fine buh-bye
you